you say your deficit Hawk but then you
just said no I go you the people if you
say you said your deficit hot but then
you say of course you wouldn't submit a
balanced budget i said is compared to my
Republican friends who talk a whole lot
about sure the deficit who then go to
war and don't pay for it give you tax
breaks to billionaires don't pay for it
or offset it yes I have a dumb ass or
what about your view of the importance
as a deficit Hawk up so you were
president for eight years would you
aspire to year-by-year bring down the
deficit depends on the economic
situation I think the deficit is an
important issue but i'll tell you what i
think is a more important issue what is
more important is creating millions of
jobs that our people need and rebuilding
our infrastructure making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
making sure that we do not continue to
have the highest rate of childhood
poverty of any major country on Earth
those issues in fact are more important
to me than the deficit but the deficit
is important